this uh
talk will be one that you can
dip into any time it doesn't have to go
in a sequence of anything
and it's only going to be taught to you
or because
you will be getting details
i think i can call them secrets because
uh i hold the weapons scrolls
cytosensing not many people hold them
and he used to set up at night
and that's another story right each one
for each
student depending on what he'd seen the
student before
but the accuracy had to be done over and
over until he was happy
i remember taking my first scroll three
times
i didn't i've put this in a youtube
video
it wasn't i had to i'd found it
i passed it on the first one but he
wanted me
out on seminars to show other people how
it should be done
so the biggest problem
we have as an individual is
we we fear getting it wrong
i've made a youtube video on this but uh
this one i want to give you
detail to go with it
i don't think there's any student out
there that doesn't
uh worry about getting it right
you know you stand in front of your joe
and you
you're almost worried about will you
pick it up right
if you are of an arrogant nature
you should work on that and try and
become more humble because if you don't
consider will i get it right
before you start then you're not
sensitive and you have to be sensitive
to go even deeper that we'll talk about
in later
films you have to know your
partner you have to be able to read
instincts
and you can't do that if you're busy
wowing about
how you're going to pick up the joe or
you perform the technique right
so this is what i'd like you to do
let's say you're going to do the
20 jokes very
before you do each one i'd like you to
consider
the see how you feel
inside and then
you must throw that away
clear your mind you can do it by
either breathing out or close the eyes
slowly and then we open them but
slowly this will give you like a like a
windscreen wiper
clearing it only takes that second
to switch from
thinking to doing
if you can do that each time
stand there try to get but you're trying
to reach a blank
mind okay so stand there
let's just say the first um
so put the joe down
remember not to look down put the joe
down
if you want to look down the first time
then you can
but know you're doing it so stand there
with your joe
watch your own reactions place the joe
down
it's good once you get to the point
where you don't have to worry
you say the thing is why people look
down
and i'm watching third down six stands
i'm watching
all downs and they're still looking down
i can't say names but they are
still looking down you'll see them on
facebook and youtube
once they've finished the technique they
look down this is a weakness
it means that they don't even know
it's the inadequacy that's been built in
so i'd like you to try to remove that so
that we make
we get you from a human being thinking
to a martial artist's thinking
okay so it's because when they put their
joe down
this little thing in their mind says is
it in the right place
yes it is important but it's not
important enough to disturb
what you wish to do if it's five
centimeters out it's not the end of the
world
you know the chokzuki is more important
the actual
power of hitting the person in the chest
and stopping their heart
building coke you letting the key
flow through your body the key
and cannot flow if you're worried about
is your joe in the right place so
if we then moved on to let's say the 13
carter what i'd like you to do
is think first okay i'm going to do the
carter
try to clear your mind don't worry about
where the joe is where it's starting now
just place it down
and try to do the whole carter
your mind is so fast that it will tell
you if you make a mistake through it
but try not to stop so keep doing it
over and over until your mind can pass
through that blip
let's say you get a blip on four to five
or from five to six or wherever it is
your mind will go that's wrong
but of course you won't be by the time
you've said those words
that's wrong however fast you say that
you will be on to another two or three
movements so that means that those two
or three movements
don't have the key and coke you're in
them because they're
what i call empty moves
to the onlooker they can't see this
but you've switched off your key flow
and your
co-q flow
okay so
those of you who want to write in you
can those who
i have one-to-ones with and personal
one-to-one training we can look at all
these points and i can watch you
and i can through even the
the electronic world i should be able to
pick up
whether you're thinking concentrating on
the wrong
items but we'll see okay
so that's what i would like you to do
listen to this tape
and and
try to first check what you're doing
and why you're thinking it and it's fine
whatever you're thinking
but when you're going to come to the
doing you must just
do it if you have a problem with
let's say five to six six to seven if
you have a problem
do take it and break it down one at a
time
just keep going over five to six five to
six
five to six but do it like a suburbi
so study it make precision
if it's a ski or a strike
if you're doing it outside or inside
find an object like the end of a door
handle
or if it's outside a nail on a fence
or even put a small dot somewhere with a
bio
that you think can be safely placed
ski always to that dot strike always to
that dot
you've got a focus you're you're you're
making something as a target that you
can
work to slowly slowly you will build the
coke you
you will build the power towards that
dot towards that handle
that light switch so that becomes
your focus that becomes the chest on a
person
the knee it becomes an item
it could be a plug lower down in the
room
but make it your focus don't allow the
mind to wander off
okay so please try this and
it will take perhaps a few months
and all these films on this
patreon site need work
you might just look at them and enjoy
them or you may
think oh i'll work on that but each film
is designed for you to work on for a
long long period
not just something to to browse
if you want to browse it then just do it
hoping that your memory banks will take
absorb some
but these are teaching videos
not enjoyable videos where you're going
to have
fun you'll have fun when you've achieved
all the things i'm telling you thanks
for your time